bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct sur tv fil 78 heures du
7-8 l'aktu le journal de la rédaction
voici les principaux titres de ce
mercredi verdict pour la femme monique
abdou poursuivi pour outrage lors d'un
contrôle de police mouvement théâtral en
juillet dernier cassandra belin écopent
de sursis et 250 euros damende elle
n'était pas présente ce matin au
tribunal de verser l'huile et véronique
côté millard briguer un nouveau mandat
l'annoncent officiellement ce soir nous
revenons aussi avec elle sur cette
intercommunalité avec plaisir et
villepreux qu'elle rejette et puis coup
d'envoi des soldes d'hiver cinq semaines
de bonnes affaires et selon les derniers
sondages 80% des français ont
l'intention d'en profiter
l'image du jour c'est donc à ses clients
les bras chargés de sacs dans les
centres commerciaux les soldes de
débuter en période de crise les bonnes
affaires sont les bienvenues pour les
commerçants le moment aussi crucial les
soldes ont perdu de leur attrait en
raison des promotions à l'année sur les
sites internet notamment résultat de
nombreux -50% s'affiche dès la première
démarque l essentiel du chiffre
d'affaires se jouera d'ici à dimanche
nous reviendrons un peu plus tard dans
ce journal sur ce premier jour de soldes
pour l'instant en direction à versailles
et son tribunal la femme au niqab
poursuivi pour outrage lors d'un
contrôle de police mouvementée à trappes
en juillet dernier a été condamné ce
matin un mois de prison avec sursis et
150 euros d'un monde on retiendra
également que le tribunal a jugé
irrecevable la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité posée sur
l'interdiction du voile intégral par les
avocats de cassandra belin anthony rech
et jonathan et vehlmann pour les
précisions
malgré son absence au tribunal
correctionnel de versailles cassandra
belin jeune femme voilée de trappes a
été condamné à un mois de prison avec
sursis et à 150 euros d'amendé pour
avoir refusé un contrôle d'identité en
juillet dernier c'est plus qu'un rappel
à la loi c'est un rappel aux principes
fondamentaux qui qui fonde la façon dont
les citoyens doivent vivre ensemble dans
ce pays c'est à dire dans le cadre de la
liberté de conscience évidemment mais en
respectant avant tout les règles
citoyenne qui fondent les valeurs
communes de la république française et
les dérogations qui sont demandées à ces
règles au nom de prétendus principes
religieux et bien doivent être fermement
dans le respect des textes naturellement
mais fermement rejetées et c'est ce qui
s'est passé ce matin quand on agresse un
policier le soir on doit dormir à la
prison voilà c'est une image pour le
quai est extrêmement importante ce n'est
pas de la surenchère c'est simplement
que la police nationale ou la
gendarmerie nationale sont considérés
comme les derniers remparts de la
république et à ce titre ils sont
intouchables une absence d'ailleurs
déploré par la présidente du tribunal
qui a regretté qu'un débat ne se soit
pas engagé et qui voulait proposer à la
saint-quentinoise un stage de
citoyenneté le tribunal a également jugé
irrecevable la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité sur l'interdiction du
voile soulevée par l'avocat de la jeune
femme de 20 ans converti à l'islam dans
l'absolu ce n'est pas une décision chef
sévère mais savait que je faisais de
cette affaire une affaire de principe
notamment concernant la loi de nos 2011
sur l'interdiction du port du voile donc
ça mérite réflexion et ça mérite de
savoir si nous allons poursuivre le
combat judiciaire pas le mari de
cassandra belin qui avait étranglé un
policier le jour des faits à lui écopé
de trois mois de prison avec sursis en
novembre dernier en juillet 2013 ce
contrôle avait entraîné de violents
affrontements entre forces de l'ordre et
jeunes dans la ville saint-quentinoise
l'invité de cette édition je vous le
disais en titre véronique côté millard
bonsoir les rues des idées
clayes-sous-bois ce n'est un secret pour
personne mais vous n'avez pas encore
annoncé est ce que vous serez
officiellement candidate en mars a
profité à fait vous êtes les premiers
qui je fais donc cette annonce donc je
repars pour un mandat de six ans après
avoir à la fois mûrement réfléchi parce
que c'est un engagement et qui aussi n
est pas sans conséquence sur la vie
personnelle et familiale donc fallait
qu'elle soit acceptée et parce que j'ai
été aussi largement encouragée par des
citoyens qui souhaitent me soutenir voir
s'investir donc avec une équipe qui sera
renouvelée à 50 % véronique côté millard
candidate donc soutenu par l'ump
également dernier scrutin en 2008 vous
l'aviez emporté au second tour 51,5 %
des voix devant le socialiste jean
michel gourdon qui se présente
d'ailleurs une nouvelle fois quel est
votre état d'esprit en ce début de
campagne de se déterminer serein et très
contente de partir en 2008 il y avait
cinq listes aux élections municipales en
semble s'acheminer vers à peu près le
même schéma enfin parce que ça vous
inquiète c'est un atout non enfin ça ne
ça ne m'inquiète pas nous nous
continuons ce que nous avons commencé de
faire et après pour le moigne a qu'une
liste officiellement qui s'est annoncée
kessel ne conduit pas jean michel combes
officiellement effectivement on verra
dans les prochaines semaines si la
rumeur se confirme si on regarde tout de
même en 2012 ce n'est pas le scrutin
municipal mais le scrutin pour les
législatives la liste socialiste c'est
presque 50 9% au second tour dans votre
commune ou là au niveau de la
circonscription puisque c'était le 38%
pour les socialistes mais 59% la gauche
l'emporter dans votre commune en 2012
vous pensez que ça va se retrouver
encore sur le prochain ce que les plus
difficiles de faire campagne encore je
sélectionne les élections municipales
sont tout à fait différente ce sont des
élections locales et nous avons toujours
conduit une liste qui étayent qui
regrouperait différentes sensibilités
politiques
donc ce qui est du national est une
chose sur le local est différent je
pense que le fait d'avoir de
l'expérience
quelque part candidate aussi perdre tout
à fait mais je vous dis c'est d'une
chose donc le local et nous avons donc
je pense qu'on peut le dire on a
l'affairé la fierté partagée d'un bilan
de mandat qui est sur lequel beaucoup de
choses ont été réalisées sur la ville la
ville est très dynamique à la ville on
va juste repréciser votre première
victoire c'est en 2001 où il la ville
était alors détenu par les communistes
comme il lui est difficile c'est quoi
c'est de faire basculer une ville ou de
la conserver ensuite la conserver
c'était un peu plus difficile c'est de
la conserver après là nous sommes bons
nous avons un avantage d'avoir
l'expérience dans un contexte où
effectivement le contexte national et
plein d'incertitudes et sur lesquels on
appelait visibilité donc je pense que
c'est également un atout avec un
candidat sortant on sait la politique
qui a été menée et celle qui va qui
pourrait être reconduite le bilan le
bilan que vous mettez en avant c'est
quoi c'est ce développement économique
notamment il ya eu l'ouverture juste
avant les fêtes de fin d'année du centre
commercial où un jeune paris notamment
elle était sous bois aujourd'hui c'est
ça c'est un immense centre commercial
al atassi pas seulement parce que depuis
dix ans nous avons créé à peu près 3000
emplois donc je pense qu'on est dans les
vraiment les communes des départements
les plus dynamiques en matière de
créations d'emplois nous avons su garder
et préserver la société bull qui n'est
pas un centre commercial et qui est un
datacenter de taille européenne je pense
qu'il faut le lire il ya d'autres
sociétés importantes sur la ville
d'éclat il n'y a pas que des centres
commerciaux il est il est évident que on
a eu beaucoup de chance on a eu alpha
park un parc 2 et je le rappelle le plus
grand mur végétal du monde c'est quand
même une fierté pour la ville et one
nation qui vient de qui vient d'ouvrir
qu'il n'est pas terminé puisqu'il sera
terminée que fait donc ses commerciaux
ses talents de commerce port
la ville est ce que il ya aussi des
améliorations est-ce que ça fera partie
de votre il ya deux questions pourquoi
des centres commerciaux parce que
malheureusement la ville est mal
desservi par les transports en commun
bondés et on a une ligne de train mais
il mal desservies donc n'étaient pas
appropriés à accueillir des bureaux et
les bureaux on ne vont plus tôt au
niveau de la soeur au groupe lutte au
niveau de la défense que dans la
périphérie sur le plan financier le
développement de centres commerciaux est
attractif puisque vous savez que
maintenant la taxe sur les bureaux ne va
plus aux villes mais que nous gardons au
moins les taxes foncière et la taxe sur
la valeur commerciale va directement
ville donc vous dire que le one nation
c'est aussi et c'est pas négligeable des
recettes pour la ville qui pourrait être
estimé la hauteur de la millions d'euros
dans les clés sur le programme précis en
sport
les transports il ya des infrastructures
routières qui ont été donc mise en place
il ya des travaux qui vont avoir lieu
sur la commune voisine également sur sûr
plaisir nous avons la déviation qui a
été réalisé et pour précisément one les
chaînes y aura des redifs la navette
gratuite qui feront la gare au moins le
week end voir la semaine la gare le
centre commercial on avait été gratuite
est également le week-end et déjà à
partir de samedi à une avec qui va
partir de l'étoile pour emmener les
touristes sur one nation avec des bus et
le système sera pérennisé au début mars
donc là on est sur la question de
l'économie de ce développement des
centres commerciaux sur la question des
transports également vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure avoir longtemps réfléchi
avant de vous présenter pour cette cette
nouvelle candidature
quelles sont vos priorités sur le
prochain mandat alors viens écouter
justement c'est de continuer ce
dynamisme dans matière d'emploi
puisque nous avons un autre projet
depuis quelques années dans les terroirs
et dans les services de l'état qui
pourrait aboutir à la création de 2000
emplois avec une promet une promesse de
vente qui est signé sur le secteur qui
est dans le sud de la commune de pisanu
un nouveau centre commercial pas
seulement non une autre conception
mais bon pour le moment je ne peux pas
trop en parler mais qui pourrait être en
complémentarité avec ce qui se fait sur
50 ans ils vont des commerces des
bureaux également peut-être de
l'hôtellerie aussi un grand total voilà
il ya différents mais on reste toujours
vous savez pour qu'un projet aboutisse
il faut rester toujours très très
prudent surtout quand on en est qu'elle
a qu'à l'élaboration du projet psion de
voir sa réalisation aura l'occasion bien
évidemment de développer tous ces axes
vos axes de campagne au cours des deux
prochaines émissions notamment aux
municipales 2014 vous le savez à partir
du mois de février des débats seront
organisés sur l'antenne de télé fils
nous nous attarderons sur la question
des clayes-sous-bois bien évidemment
vous restez en plateau encore avec nous
nous allons revenir à présent sur un
dossier qui vous occupe beaucoup c'est
celui de l'intercommunalité depuis le
1er janvier les communes ont
l'obligation de se regrouper afin de
mutualiser leurs moyens les préfets ont
tranché à travers la france et dans le
département des yvelines il a été décidé
que les claies seraient regroupés à
plaisir et à villepreux seulement vous
ne voulez pas de ce mariage forcé mais
qu'en pensent les habitants des claies
micro-trottoir signé elodie moi si ça
augmente les frais non maintenant si ça
peut diminuer les frais améliorer le
transport et au oui mais voilà c'est une
question de frais oui
parce que doit tout prévu maintenant on
voit que ça se fait ça partout en brut
et un joueur moderne est connu sur le
dire aussi en russie mais ça se passe
très bien je trouve pourquoi pas bon
j'ai entendu qu'il y avait quelques
difficultés d'accord entre les
différents responsables des communes
pourquoi pas comme on dit l'union fait
la force je pense que ça coûte de
l'argent donc
si on peut rester comme on aime moi je
pense que c'est très bien tout à fait à
la condition que ça puisse permettre de
commander regrouper les moyens des
services et des véhicules et tout lé
tout ce qu'il y avait autour afin de
diminuer l'ensemble des charges des
communes s'il n'y a pas d'augmentation
d'impôts pourquoi pas après si c'est
pour que les autres puissent profiter
des nouveaux magasins que la mère a fait
construire je suis pas trop pour
justement véronique côté millard va
faire réagir dans un instant tout
d'abord quatre soirs vous nous avez
rejoint vous avez suivi ce dossier de
l'intercommunalité et vous allez
interroger dans un instant véronique
côté millard mais déjà votre réaction au
micro trottoir sur la dernière
déclaration je trouve que je trouve que
les citoyens sont très pertinents dans
leurs réponses parce qu'il posait il
pose vraiment les problèmes comme il se
pose la politique des transports vous en
avez parlé et j'ai vu en europe notre
jeu et répondent déçu dans quelques
instants surtout au niveau de
l'intercommunalité et et mutualiser les
services et des économies justement 20
entendu pourquoi pas voilà comment met
on entend pour moi non non non non il
mais il pose la question est-ce que cela
va nous permettre de réaliser des
économies etc voilà donc je pense que
les questions effectivement leurs
interrogations sont contre ce verdict
n'était pas forcément contre et vous
vous êtes content moi j'en sais pas où
était d'abord une bonne année merci mais
peut-être aussi vous souhaitez peut-être
une bonne année intercommunale la mer si
bien oui une bonne année à toi que vous
n'avez pas écouté
de toute façon nous on est on s'est
toujours positionnée pour défendre
l'intérêt des habitants je n'ai je n'ai
reçu l'arrêté de périmètre le préfet a
pris sa décision que le 26 décembre 26
semaines au 28 décembre donc maintenant
le périmètre effectivement et d'arrêter
sur sur ces trois communes qu'est ce que
vous reprochez vous parce que ça paraît
assez logique ce rapprochement trop bas
les ir évident pour eux vous avez déjà
une piscine intérieure oui alors
justement annoncé deux il ya y aller on
ne le dirons fallières il existe ce
bassin de vie existent avec les trois
communes et c'est pas le fait d'être
avec un vigoureux et plaisir qui pose de
près le problème c'est il a été évoqué
c'est la taille du périmètre déjà la
taille du périmètre n'est pas
suffisamment pertinent pour réaliser des
économies d'échelle elle va apporter des
dépenses supplémentaires elle apporte
une fiscalité additionnelle puisque vous
savez que quand on entre en
intercommunautés et ça je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on fasse beaucoup de
pédagogie par rapport aux mêmes aux
habitants la ville va déléguer des
compétences à l'intercommunalité qui est
un supra conseil municipal de trois
communes qui va décider donc de deux de
ses compétences pour la ville ce que
l'on reproche est déjà beau c'est
d'abord la méthode puisque les deux
villes ont délibéré alors il lui fallait
de la ville ont tenu du grand terence de
peintres contre la la le souhait des
claies nous notre soit depuis dix ans il
n'y a pas changé c'est de toujours à
intégrer une intercommunautés avec un
périmètre justement suffisamment large
pour pouvoir économique indique que
l'économie sont délibérés sont des
économies d'échelle a priori quand on
les écoute quoi quand où et quand on
écoute la mère de plaisir elle dit vous
avez été conviés à des réunions vous
n'avez pas souhaité assister à ces
réunions alors qu'est ce que vous
répondez
vous n'avez pas envie de rentrer dans
une polémique et encore mois - là ce
soir parce que je pense que c'est pas le
c'est pas le but simplement ce que ce
que je peux affirmer c'est que nous
n'avons jamais été organisée hors
invités à des réunions de travail que je
n'ai jamais reçu aucun compte-rendu ni
pv ni quoi que ce soit y en a eu
simplement des contacts téléphoniques ou
quand j'ai appris qu'ils allaient
délibéré je leur ai demandé de ne pas le
faire parce que on pouvait aussi à 3
demandé aux préfets de nous intégrer
dans une intercommunalité de plus large
périmètre et je rappelle que justement
et c'est très important les gens ont
parlé de transport on peut regretter que
les ces deux villes n'ai jamais voulu
intégrer le plan local de déplacement
avec la ville de avec le mec versailles
grand parc comme les clés en vacances je
les six robots sur le flash dance sur
les transports parce que c'est un sujet
important si justement veut réaliser des
économies de transport il est insensé de
penser qu'à 3 on va le trois villes on
va pouvoir mais c'est déjà bien de bus
certains débutent royale des guides pour
après intégrer une plus grand ses bras
ce n'est absolument pas un début qui
vous fera re été réalisés comme
transport vous savez bien que les lignes
de bus on va faire mon travail sur des
lignes qui vont vers saint germain vers
saint-quentin vers versailles mais on ne
m'a pas réaliser des lignes de bus sur
trois communes où il ya déjà déjà trois
gars puisque nous avons quand même 3
garnier la gare de 8 pro link life de
plaisir les klaus et d'internationaliser
elle n'a pas de sens à 3 vous nous dit
j'ai jamais été invités à des réunions
non seulement elle n'a pas de sens mais
elle n'est pas sans conséquence n'est
pas sans conséquence sur la fiscalité
des clés siens parce qu'il y aura une
fiscalité additionnelle puisque on crée
on ajoute une couche au millefeuille on
va concret un supra conseil municipal
donc il va prendre des décisions elle
n'est pas sans conséquence sur
l'autonomie la libre administration des
communes puisque nous sommes 3es que
nous sommes dans la situation nous avons
nous n'avons sommes minoritaires donc
quelles que soient les décisions que
nous pourrions être amenés à prendre on
peut
exister que vous allez la subir parce
que malgré tout les décisions qui vont
cependant à partir du 1er janvier donc
ça a déjà commencé et vous initier j'ai
pas d'ailleurs dans cette
intercommunalité n'avait pas désigné de
délégués bas pour le moment
comme je vous le disais les documents
sont arrivés donc fin faire des
souvenirs d'un consentement des images
des clayes-sous-bois il vous avez voté
contre les stades tout a failli sa tuque
ont été décidées et à sang vous le nom
de la communauté d'agglomération a été
décidée sans vous est-ce que c'est pas
un peu frustrant de faire partie d'une
mêlée d'atr communauté parce que vous
n'avez vraiment n'est de toute façon pas
le choix les présents tout est décidé
sans - est-ce que j'ai même des
convocations à ce jour on me dit vous
avez des vous avez été convoqué je n'ai
même pas été convoqué et je n'ai même
pas d'évêque justement là le tout est
décidé que la mairie de plaisir nous a
fait parvenir un courrier qui datait du
9 octobre vous étiez officiellement on
le voit vous étiez officiellement
invités vous nous dites vous vous n'avez
l'avant et et qu'on veut qu'aucune
réunion de travail a reçu ce courrier
que l'américain est comment dire
propre à ces derniers même télé coup de
téléphone lui même appel téléphonique ni
quoi que ce soit ça faisait mal j'aime
pas quand même quelques mares et et
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
pour les habitants des claies par
exemple si demain entre en gros quand
j'ai appelé la mairie de plaisir on m'a
dit entre le entre le 20 janvier et le
31 janvier y aura la première réunion du
conseil communautaire coûtait en à
laquelle on serait allé déjeuner vient
de recevoir la même location à laquelle
vous serez vous cette nouvelle avatar
pas encore à l'axé mais il est vrai que
vous négligez net à l'occasion avec la
religion bien oui monsieur me rendrait
bien sûr c'est l'abonnement vous n'avez
pas désigné de délégués mais chaque
chose en chaque chose en son temps voilà
chaque chose est-ce que c'est pas pour
les habitants des plaines
écoutez je ne sais pas mais nous on est
on est vous savez si la ville s'est
développée comme et s'est développée
qu'on a sorti les projets qu'on a qu'on
a pu avoir sur la commune c'est parce
qu'on a toujours fait preuve d'une
grande détermination et d'une d'un
certain après il faut être cohérent dans
ses actions cette intercommunalité elle
est extrêmement défavorable aux
cliniciens et elle va être pénalisantes
pour eux donc je me dois aussi de ne pas
accepter les d'inacceptables les larves
ou police la ville voulait aussi saisir
un cabinet juridique aux armées pour
attaquer maintenant c'est vrai m nous
avons saisi un cabinet toi quels
résultats vous savez que lorsqu'on
saisit un cabinet juridique s'est
commise elle en attendant d'avoir un
avis quelle est votre position à vis de
toute façon notre position la porte est
ouverte oui tout va mais cette position
est de toute façon va être très c'est
pour ça que la situation était ces us
parce qu'on est à trois mois des
élections on va nommer on va nommer déjà
des personnes qui ne seront pas
forcément les mêmes autour de la table
parce qu'on ne sait pas qui sont les
élections municipales donc on va
installer des personnes et
financièrement donner des délégations et
caetera et peut-être faire des
transferts de personnels pour peut-être
de moi et là et qui sera demain ça sera
autrement et puis comme je le rappelle
les intercommunalités et c'est le
souhaite quand même du goût c'est le
souhait du gouvernement actuel c'est la
pertinence des territoires des lois est
passé avec des seuils pour la grande
couronne de 200000 habitants il le fait
parce que justement on monte des projets
clés puisse éventuellement réaliser des
économies ou travailler sur des modes
comme les transports ils font et ça ça
prouve encore évolué après les
municipales et de toute façon il ya
d'autres intercommunalités qui sont
aussi dans ses plates la paix mais je
vous rappelle que le préfet de région
dans la loi actuelle demande que
l'arrêté de périmètre soit fait d'ici au
mois de septembre 2014 donc de toutes
façons l'intercommunalité telle qu'elle
est actuellement ne sera que très très
provisoire mais il faudra tout
recommencer donc ça veut dire
vous allez vers quelle intercommunalité
au départ vous vouliez versailles grand
parc la porte s'est fermée vous aviez
souhaité saint quentin en yvelines on a
bien senti que la porte se fermait aussi
alors donne nous sommes de nos vies de
l'attractivité madone réponse semble
souffrir parce que nous avons été voilà
mais
plutôt s'il ya une logique avec 50,1
surtout avec le projet dont je vous ai
parlé aux côtés de del en cours après
s'il faut aller avec quelqu'un de bien
sûr avec nos deux collègues de plaisir
et de ville près ça ne posera aucun
problème
le dossier
catherine verser des milliards d'êtres
venu nous expliquer votre point de vue
sur cette intercommunalité je rappelle
aussi que vous êtes partir de ce soir
officiellement candidate au scrutin de
mars vous l'avait annoncé au début de ce
journal nous poursuivons avec un autre
sujet polémique et politiques également
le nouveau découpage électoral en vue
des prochaines élections cantonales ce
matin il ya une séance exceptionnelle du
conseil général la majorité de droite a
tenu à marquer son mécontentement
le département pourrait passer en 2015
de 39 à 21 cantons pour tenir compte des
évolutions démographiques
par exemple certains cantons compte
quinze mille habitants et d'autres 60000
comme celui de montigny le bretonneux
autre nouveauté deux conseillers
généraux siègeront par canton au lieu de
1 actuellement avec obligation de parité
hommes femmes aujourd'hui le conseil
général des yvelines comprend cinq
femmes pour 34 hommes un projet qui
n'est pas du goût de l'assemblée
majoritaire une réunion extraordinaire
du conseil général a été convoqué pour
rendre un avis une séance en l'absence
du président alain schmitt une absence
remarquée mais avec un pierre bellier
plus que jamais leader de la fronde
contre un découpage qu'ils jugent
politiciens dans les yvelines qui sont
pas embêtés ils n'ont pas cherché à voir
si c'était cohérent avec les
intercommunalités cohérent avec les
territoires d'action sociale du
département ils ont pris très exactement
le résultat du premier tour des
élections régionales de 2010 et partout
le parti socialiste et arrive en tête
ils ont fait des cantons voilà donc
c'est un charcutage il n'y a pas de
charcutage il n'y a pas de découpage il
y assure il ya tout simplement une
l'application de la loi
sur la parité d'abord c'est quand même
étonnant que le président de conseil
général ne soit pas là pour présider
cette science dite extraordinaire encore
une fois qui nous paraît tout à fait une
mascarade tout simplement pour remettre
en piste certaines personnes les
conseillers généraux de gauche ont
quitté la séance dès le début sans
prendre part au débat évoquant une
mascarade politique seul élu de
l'opposition rester sur les bancs du
conseil général à jeanine marie l'élu
socialiste du canton de trappes estime
que les discussions sont nécessaires que
défend
le projet de découpage sur des principes
de bases et non sur des arrière-pensées
politiques nous avons encore quelques
mois devant nous avant de lancer au
moins jusqu'à fin juin pour comment dire
travailler ensemble à avoir quelque
chose qui respecte ce qui est dans ce
département au final les élus présents
ont décidé d'émettre à l'unanimité un
avis défavorable au projet de décret du
gouvernement et le conseil général va
proposer un autre découpage un exemple
train aujourd'hui ville canton en 2015
elle pourrait se voir associé selon le
gouvernement aux villes de maurepas
elancourt la verrière dans le projet du
conseil général la verrière ville
communiste basculerait dans un canton de
voisins-le-bretonneux plutôt à droite un
débat que l'on aura compris symbolique
et très politique
l actualité qui intéresse le plus
forcément tout à chacun ce sont ces
premiers jours de soldes qui ont débuté
nous sommes rendus à l'ouverture d'un
supermarché à maurepas les clients ont
bien entendu répondu présent l'enseigne
s'attend malgré tout à une baisse de la
fréquentation cette année de l'ère
cambier elodie moines étaient à
l'ouverture du rideau
dans ce supermarché les salariés ont
passé une partie de la nuit à étiqueter
à placer les produits à quelques minutes
de l'ouverture on finalise les
rayonnages tout doit être prêt pour
l'arrivée des clients 8h30 le rideau se
lève derrière une centaine de personnes
bien décidées à profiter des soldes
premier arrivé premier servi le meilleur
à faire ses premiers jours c'est parmi
les premières armes
le magasin propose des réductions allant
jusqu'à -70% de quoi faire des affaires
et là à chacun sa technique il y a ceux
qui fouillent et ceux qui ont bien
préparé leur
j'ai fait mon opéra j'espère que j'ai
trouvé mon bonheur dans tous les cas les
caddies se remplissent vite même si
cette année l'enseigne prévoit une
baisse de la fréquentation
c'est vrai que le
l'élasticité moins importante quand même
que ce qu'on pouvait connaître il ya
quelques années parce que ben oui a
beaucoup beaucoup de promotions et de
l'opération tout au long de l'année donc
ça et que ça dit vu quand même un petit
peu un petit peu l'impact des soldes
malgré tout il reste quand même un delta
qui est non négligeable les magasins de
vêtements plus particulièrement ont
lancé des ventes privées des soldes
avant les soldes c'est tout de même dans
le textile que ce supermarché compte
faire son plus gros chiffre d'affaires
en grève générale les ventes du rayon
vêtements atteignent 100 mille euros le
premier jour et en cinq semaines de
soldes de 10 à 12% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel malgré la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat 62% des français devraient
dépenser plus de 100 euros pour les
soldes une donnée confirmée par les
clients de ce magasin si j'arrive à tout
trouvé aux alentours 500 600 euros
passant
il reste jusqu'au 11 février pour
profiter des soldes dans ce magasin si
les collections passées ne sont pas
écoulés d'ici là une partie du stock
sera donné à des associations
après les excès des fêtes il faut
maintenant se reprendre un peu de sport
après des heures passées à table
quelques conseils pour retrouver la
forme et yolaine 13 est allé poser la
question à une diététicienne yvelinoise
avant tout ne pas faire un régime
restrictif
c'est important de manger équilibré et
surtout d'apporter à son corps ce dont
il a besoin pour se reconstruire et puis
pour l'aider à déstocker durablement
donc c'est la modération on voir les
quantités aliments qu'ils consomment
donc manger lentement bien mastiquer et
puis travailler sur la qualité aussi
d'alimentation pour et bien que les
apports caloriques ne soit pas aussi
important que choisir des aliments plus
intéressant nutritionnellement est moins
calorique voilà et puis de cormont
surtout de prendre plaisir à manger de
manger lentement de mastiquer et puis le
faire un peu d'activité en parallèle
pour les étés à déstocker plus
rapidement fin du journal pour ce
mercredi 8 janvier n'oubliez pas ce soir
que vous avez rendez vous avec aurélia
de bissy pour une nouvelle édition de
kiosques le magazine culturel de à la
rédaction je vous retrouve demain à 18h
en direct nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu
excellente soirée